un palestino de 20 años murió y otros
dos resultaron heridos en una nueva
redada del ejército israelí en la luz
una de las ciudades es de Jordania
ocupada donde se han producido más
incursiones militares en el último año y
medio con vehículos blindados o las
fuerzas israelíes entraron en la ciudad
para demorar la vivienda de Osama tahuil
un miembro de La milicia Guarida de los
leones que está preso acusado de
participar en el asesinato del Soldado
israelí ido Baruc en octubre pasado en
los enfrentamientos el ejército israelí
mató al joven de un disparo en la cabeza
según el Ministerio de salud palestino
mientras que entre los heridos uno se
encuentra en estado crítico además en la
media luna roja Palestina reportó que
170 personas debieron ser tratadas por
síntomas de asfixia a causa de los gases
lacrimógenos arrojados por las tropas
israelíes horas después las fuerzas
israelíes en derribaron la casa familiar
de tahuil en la que también vivían los
padres y la hermana del atacante
mientras que también está programada la
destrucción de las viviendas de los
otros los dos acusados de participar en
el ataque contra el soldado Baruc estas
demoliciones son una práctica habitual
de Israel que la se justifica como un
elemento de disuasión pero es denunciada
por los grupos de Derechos Humanos como
un castigo colectivo Injusto e incluso
dentro del establecimiento de seguridad
de Israel es cuestionada su efectividad
en desalentar posibles futuros ataques
así en este año el más mortífero desde
la segunda intifada ya son al menos 125
los palestinos muertos por fuego israelí
en Jordania ocupada entre ellos en
varios civiles y 21 menores